breast cancer is the most common form of  cancer in women today knowing more about  your own breast Anatomy can help you in  early cancer detection and prevention  your breasts are connected to small  masses of tissue called lymph nodes by  way of limp vessels the lymph nodes are  responsible for collecting bacteria  cancer cells and other unhealthy  material you have groups of these lymph  nodes under your arms above your  collarbones and behind your breastbone  as well as in other parts of your body  each breast is made up of lobes lobules  and ducts the lobes consist of smaller  lobules that contain groups of tiny milk  producing glands when a breast is  producing milk it passes through the  ducts into the nipple where it exits the  body breast cancer most commonly  develops in the lobules glands and ducts  of the breast